hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in to another episode about to be
talked this episode is brought to you by
el cajon hall hmm you know you won't
you're no konami's you're gonna ride
you're getting a lawsuit from jihadi el
cajon are like get yourself a motorcycle
from them down there in el cajon
california and while you're there you
might want to move there cuz it's
beautiful spicer loves it down there yet
the sea air and all kinds of great stuff
and great riding helko gnarly got all
kinds of good [ __ ] go sim don't sleep
what's going on guys we're back baby
yeah speaking of no sleep you know uh 0
so you're on the road for forever tour
bus life uh Steve you were everywhere
and I have two kids so we're ready to
roll yeah Steve Henry's with us here
today and Spicer's here and where our
topic today is a favorite summer
vacation which we're going to get into
Steve drove his 2016 Prius through 48
states yes there's yeah in California
went to Utah Arizona and New Mexico went
down south and it went up the eastern
seaboard there went to Canada acta went
to Canada yeah came back down through
Detroit hey hey I went back across the
country could you the cow did you [ __ ]
out on any of them and like cut through
four corners and be like for stage [ __ ]
and then if I keep going or whatever did
it start on Florida I was yeah I missed
out on Florida went to Pensacola and in
ditched Florida I went to Alabama but I
did meet all the whole guy in New Mexico
who said i could stand somewhere and be
in four corners four corners yeah I
didn't want to drive 30 miles back stiva
he did this all on his own and we ran
into each other twice once when I was
headlining at the Comedy Works so we got
to do a spot there I think steve was
just trying to stalk you and you kept
going different
like three miles back he's playing
pokeyman and I was the dude good this
old Navajo tracker have you seen this
man and he's like yeah smoke signals are
going to utah yes honey because I I did
ask Dean about his travel dates for the
summer and I remember looking at a
couple of them thinking whoa we might
actually bump into each other but we
bumped into each other twice which is
crazy there are in atlantic city of all
play we had a great time in atlantic
city we're at the taj madam yeah which
is a spanish forgot to take it down the
touch me dump taj mahal which they just
announced that it's going out of
business yes and it's so funny because i
have been [ __ ] on the place for
about three weeks now and one of the
funniest things about it is and now it
makes all kinds of sense as we were
checking in at like 6am the tour bus
rolls in and and usually the tour
manager will say hey every we're here
the key here's your key in the hands
your key goes in and gets the keys and
it you're going so there's like 10 guys
on the bus and they all go upstairs I go
into my room and I look notice there's
no blanket oh it's just a sheet in and a
[ __ ] pillow and I didn't matter
because it's boiling I mean boy are they
so I got [ __ ] I'm out I sleep and
round one I run into the other guys and
they're like oh what a nightmare I had
to [ __ ] I had to get like four hours
guy City open the first room there's
just a naked couple in there he could
have got shot the guys like what the
[ __ ] going on he's like well hold on
sir he goes down gets another key goes
up piss stains like someone just took a
piss all over the bed that's why the
next one had blood what the [ __ ] here's
the hypothetical for you guys yeah blood
or piss stains you gotta stay in one of
the rooms which room do you pass me
can't get aids from piss right
don't think you're gonna get aids from a
blood stain that snow murder I might I
might pick blood yeah because blood
doesn't stink yeah I want to be wrapping
myself up in it but I want to be in a
peru mall there be in blood room I'd be
like the guy probably deserved it yeah
other than like someone paid a lot of
money to get peed on in this room yeah
well I figured it out once they announce
they're closin it was they just didn't
have any more maid service oh so I think
what they're doing is that s Steve the
building is monstrous and we at week we
got the [ __ ] penthouse we were on the
[ __ ] now after at the [ __ ] room I got
upgraded another guy goes I'm sporting
you can have my room a guy on the tour
and we go up Steve and I we open the
door it's the dual doors the cloud yeah
all right with the [ __ ] balcony with
views of entire Atlantic City all the
way down the beach were thousands of
seagulls and it was full moon you know
you're going into a
three-thousand-dollar a night room when
you go into the room and then all of a
sudden you turn a corner yeah you turn
another corner when you go in through
the bathroom there's two bathrooms it
had a giant honeymoon hot tub and in the
in the master bedroom who wears mirrors
in America i'ma see
what's happening to this property well
first of all atlantic city is it gonna
be around in 10 years like what the [ __ ]
it's well immediately i did some
research uh because i was like what is
going on here yeah me atlantic city is
bruce springsteen yeah I've been [ __ ]
hearing that song all my life I've been
here in Atlantic City and it's got the
classic boardwalk boardwalk empire yeah
it's got all the old roller coasters and
the [ __ ] you know the game carnival
yeah that shit's cool man um but what
happened was the two things there's a
massive strike going on there okay and I
guess and this is where is your website
yeah they're outside come on [ __ ]
[ __ ] you others kids vacation in the
Trump has nothing to do with the
property against Trump yeah he sold it
long time ago these people don't even
know who they're working for you know to
me and the people rent his name what's
up but I just like the idea that they're
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'll such a right
so we um well I found out what's going
on so the strike has been going on I
guess for months and they said it cost
him tens of millions a day I'm like come
on Tenten million's a day anyway
whatever it costs they struck so long
that it was done huh and so I started
asking around why at my exit he was dead
because there's for the showboats close
yeah there's just giant casino towers it
looks like scooby-doo episode just
haunted hotels yeah and they said that
all the Indian casinos which we played a
couple indian casinos on the tour that
are beautiful and a new and massive
wiped out atlantic city cuz now no
longer was that a destination of the
only place you could gamble on the east
coast it was like either vegas west
coast or there and it wiped it out and
people stopped going you know and other
people just go to like the Jersey Shore
boardwalk Waka they with a family that
if they're not gambling so that's really
what's going on there I got a call Oh
crab it real quick what's going on man
you're on the air
hey what's going on DDR yeah how are you
who's calling okay man this is Vince
Vince where he called from Atlantic City
coming from la man i'll [ __ ] a rear la
call how are you man what do you would
he got you got any questions no man you
were talking about like my favorite like
summer oh yeah well we did for summer
and stuff like that totally and then one
time you know met me and my band the
Mormons were like travel getting record
across the country and they're like one
of the favorite time that we had was
just like sitting around the van talking
about music and Howard Stern ballsack
hidden with the high wow you guys tough
ball sack did he hang up or baba booey
and all that stuff I only like Baba
Booey Baba Booey man I love Howard Stern
I was just at the howard stern studios i
didn't get to go in i was doing Eddie
trunk you have to go you have to at
least get up on the wrap-up show man I
want to like get in there I'll trying
man actually as I was leaving I ran into
one of the interns and he said oh I 18
and I knew the guy and he said next time
I come to town I could do some of the
prank calls for them which this guy said
I'm [ __ ] in so then you have to do it
dude that studio is beautiful that place
man what a XM radio is just right there
in the right across street from Radio
City Music Hall it yet you get off the
[ __ ] f train and walk right in I was
like oh this is where I need to be your
buddy Marin was on our do what you hear
I'm on their know who's that that was
like actually maybe like a year ago or
something like that he was he was good
on there he was nervous though you're
talking about it you know I must have
heard that and just drawn a blank you
know but if not I'm gonna fire that up
again but thanks for calling in dude hey
thanks man you don't see ya yeah okay
what were you saying Steve I was going
to say that driving across the country I
noticed in a lot of states that there's
a lot of Indian casinos just outside the
main neighborhoods and like
Montana Oklahoma Texas of course
California and Nevada and then I didn't
know it dad about New Jersey but yeah
they're popping up all over the place if
you're a gambler in a lot of trouble
hahahaha we did one in Verona New York
which is six hours i believe from
Atlantic City and it was beautiful uh I
forgot what it's called like the trade
winds or something like that but the
thing was massive it had an incredible
concert venue that held five thousand
which I saw all kinds of comics had done
it like BRR yeah and you know all these
dudes over the years and then they had a
cool ass like 700 cedar that looked like
your classic Vegas showroom real dark
with the brown stage and in the cool
booths and [ __ ] that's awesome that's a
[ __ ] great room but it was in the
middle of nowhere though and when I was
day when I was driving now from Oregon I
crossed over the California border and
within maybe 60 miles there was a casino
right in my face like yeah come here and
hang out I mean in California another
now for Nia right after you get over the
border of Oregon there's nothing there
nothing yeah that's like Mount Shasta I
love the ANA cocina it looks like some
people say you ever heard that that that
[ __ ] myth that people think that
there's like a government inside mount
shop I love that Yeah Yeah right like
inside there's like a secret society
that's really run in America it that's
what happens when you cruise or the
right hitchhiker who has peyote it
starts giving me all that kind of [ __ ]
we got another cup but that's what he
said he's out you know what's going on
up there
no way hey what's going on you're on the
air man like candles are lit who's
calling what what's up man this is joe
i'm calling from Louisville Kentucky Oh
Kentucky badass we're first call ever
from Kentucky what's happening well it's
Louisville so not really Kentucky if you
ever come visit you'll know the
difference once you get outside the city
okay okay now I matters just saw the
Instagram person's like hey man what's
up with vacation talk yeah well what's
your favorite summer vacation uh what
since my wife have been married we've
been to her homeland in Puerto Rico four
times hey man nice it is we bet it's
beautiful I've been there with the
Rolling Stones is spectacular I mean
from like you can go to the mountain and
then 10 minutes later you're on beach
and then 10 minutes later you're in the
forest that's California we know it's
amazing they got [ __ ] fighting their
legal to have you gone to that no no
[ __ ] fighting I've been to the drag
races where all the crazy for you can do
is like a rotary engine so it's like you
know not under horsepower weed eaters
and stuff it's this training I was like
I couldn't even believe they had
cockfighting I was like oh yeah I gotta
go to that you know you think it's gonna
be cruel like you're not even you forget
you forget that it's actual animals you
know what I mean and then you get during
the hill this is kind of [ __ ] you know
like immediately skill I feel dirty I'm
out of here he just [ __ ] leave and it
was this giant arena with full of people
I never seen someone bit like midday
just in their gambling man it's like
it's it's a strange thing the roosters
come down from the roof and they spin
these plastic boxes they can see each
other and they got the blades and the
feet you know it's like oh man it's
dirty but the beaches are beautiful
there and it's part of us a crazy yeah
man you go down there no Passport
everything you know cost like a third
list and you're you know your money
doesn't go as far but you know as far as
I going to international
but it's awesome and we love it we're
going back next August so I can't wait
it can be often did you meet your lady
there on a vacation or online no no her
mom her mom's guide moves Kentucky for
her her dad's job and uh and so we met
here locally and then in we've been
married for nine years and we've been to
Puerto Rico for tops so if it's trip
yeah man it's awesome I bet I bet like
Trump doesn't like that you know your
lady out there we got to get these
people out of here she's like I'm
American I don't what kind of American
are you yeah mom I love it thanks for
calling in man alright man see you later
thanks for the thanks for the podcast
man it's great we got it thank you so
much man yeah [ __ ] Puerto Rica you
been there spice hold up into Puerto
Rico Oh Bermuda number muta which is not
you know all right whatever kind of not
the same but the same the same a
beautiful beautiful i don't even been to
Hawaii whoa he's or not I need to go
it's a long flight it's yeah I feel like
if you're gonna go from anywhere from LA
or San Diego is where you go from though
going to Hawaii I went to Bermuda when I
lived in Houston and that's kind of like
the closest at like the closest coral
reef right whatever is Bermudan that's
not that long of a flight but I love get
in the way it's just harder and harder
to do as you get older I think you did
it recently remember with the rich
people and they are the cool setup oh
yeah I definitely remember that when new
mexico it's [ __ ] amazing yeah but
it's harder and harder to do to find
that time when you know my schedules
clear the wife schedules clear right now
the kids we can kind of schlep them
around but pretty soon it's like they'll
be in school and you can't just I mean
sometimes you can be like you're gone
for a week we're going skiing or
whatever but yeah it gets harder like
when you got called to go on tour on
this tour did you have to like clear any
other [ __ ] up or is just like bags
packed here I go that's it's so great
about the number one thing about being
single with zero [ __ ] but you had to
have had some gigs or so like at what I
can his headline in Toronto yeah and
then i thought i would i called them and
said here's the deal because i never
cancel your any gigs
yep the one ever for my neck when I
thought I had cancer in Reno at the
Laugh Factory and still [ __ ] pissed
about that I missed out on money yeah
there's my rent yeah you're just too big
of a [ __ ] to go perform oh yeah goddamn
cyanide man I was backwards money when I
got there to get a nut you know but um
anyway I called up Toronto Booker and I
said hey dude I don't want to cancel on
you so let me run this by I've got this
Allison change to her and it's exactly
the same time as why I'm in Toronto but
it ends in New York and when I'm done
well I can fly up to Toronto and do the
following week or the week other and
it's a new club so he goes yeah that
sounds good agar are you sure he goes
yeah so now I go oh cool I've got a I've
got two bookings yeah I got the tour and
then this and then as soon as I Brooke
doing everything he texts me like two
days later said yeah I don't know man
maybe some day a time down down down the
road like scepter he [ __ ] me because
the amount of money of course I was
going to do the Allison chain store but
the amount of money of the Toronto gig
and one other gig I was going to do was
the same money as alice in chains hmm
yeah just doing four gigs right but
house in chains was way more phones a
new our new our material one more person
ages and just [ __ ] epic being out on
tour of the rock band you know free food
wait like kings man every night they had
like [ __ ] shafts and [ __ ] Steve a
deal up right oh that salmon was so good
oh yeah
they're like healthy food and then they
got garbage yeah have gluten yep hey
salmon chicken all coming all types of
stuff yeah I wanted to put everything in
my bag and just take it and then when we
left everyone was leaving there's all
this food still sitting there yeah
they're like take whatever you want but
we're [ __ ] it ate like three times
but we took a bag of waters oh my god
we're going to eat you we're going to
the casino like straight white trash
yeah those are my trash but I was okay I
got this big gonna don't bag I've got my
own bag just like shop shop shop shop
but there were bottled waters you know
so cycle uncle and they wait like a
thousand pound we're talking Fiji we're
not talking about that Nestle crap like
that good except you're not talking
about your house here by drinking water
Oh Jake from that after my mouth and
then Dean gave me a tour of the bust the
bus tour bus tour bus I've never been on
one I mean I've been on like a greyhound
but this they're kind of the same thing
right maybe I know maybe want to go on
to her oh it's so nice right great you
got the back lounge is where I slept
because nobody liked the backgrounds
they say no it's over the wheels it's
too bouncy but i like it because it's
it's like your own bed way like spread
out yeah yeah you got plasma screen and
you guys like a nice cold drinks and and
so i was back there chillin and I do
like the bunk so too cuz you can [ __ ]
I mean you disappear back out in a bunk
you know but yeah it took Steve on there
and then we drove up from Atlantic City
to New York which was fun as [ __ ] 700
700 pain stops yeah what a [ __ ]
right like people are we complain about
like the Golden Gate Bridge is five
bucks or ten bucks 50 now every stop was
like [ __ ] on that thing that's like
two two dollars two dollars and then 10
bucks at one point to go through a
tunnel yeah to go through the Holland
Tunnel yeah New York is no joke cuz i
used to live there in 86 86 288 and I
remember my dad used to always paid for
the tolls they were like back then like
eight bucks but man they've gone up I
don't understand how people go back and
forth they have to be broke they work
every day yeah they just nickel and
diming you get one of those passes you
don't even know you're doing it is like
poop and you've bought like it a bill a
new [ __ ] turntable every month or
whatever and it's like [ __ ] we figured
it out let's say you make uh what's a me
yeah 35 bucks an hour and your first
hour of your day at work is free you're
working for free yeah because you got
you got the toes gas and lunch yeah and
if you're coming from New Jersey some
people are probably commuting into the
city forget it and then parking that's
why you should just take public
transportation that's why the public
transportation is so good there but even
though public transportation is amazing
in New York the traffic is still
ridiculous it's just a man hat traffic's
crazy man it's like like I got in a town
car I was going somewhere and the oh
it's going to see gnr at metlife mm-hmm
and just to go maybe I think it was
three miles was an hour oh wow like on a
sucker's it was a Sunday and everybody
was in the city shopping and [ __ ] yeah I
was like this is [ __ ] yeah I mean I
couldn't believe it I realized something
while i was in new york and i was
telling steve this and i don't know if i
told you this but I need both coasts in
my life now like I was immediately like
oh I gotta I gotta move here yeah you
know the whole time I seeing that but
then as soon as I landed here I was like
oh yeah that's right what I need both
I'm gonna be Ari Shaffir I know I'm
doing for that that's I'm trying to
figure out right now so if you're
listening this podcast you got a couch I
can sleep on I want to go to New York
every other month yeah I do about six
days a comedy and come home every other
month yeah this new york fits Dean's
personality cos deanza Walker he likes
to explore that's all that island is man
just take the subway and just explore
left to right and look about the comedy
clubs in the middle it's perfect could
tell you where and
York for a while because you really slim
down the cocaine of New York's really
good you've been taking care of yourself
you know just going on non-stop yeah
cokin and walking coconut vodka I was
just waiting for pictures on these
Instagram and Twitter of him on the
subway just taking secret pictures of
people doing crazy stuff oh yeah they
you know it's funny because you marin as
a great joke about New York and I'm not
going to do it but as I was in New York
the whole time I kept thinking Amarin's
joke just dying but you know you're on a
subway and I love the subways and as I'm
getting older I just like trains and
subways man I've been so used to ride
and have to be alert the whole time yeah
and I am Angie I am pretty blown away
how people just walk around and look at
the phones old time in New York and I'm
like is anything wrong to you haha here
to me I've been wondering that for years
like why aren't there more carjackings
people should their phones should be
getting taken even more like why would I
take your purse that's like two hundred
dollars while I wouldn't take the iphone
that's 600 some of these phones are
eight hundred dollars yeah and you're
taking the purse come on dude hahaha so
it's a present I'm on there and every
day you get this guy that comes on and
he just comes in the car goes ok can I
don't know what's attention I'm
currently out of work and I need some
change I would like to get a Carl's jr.
western double bacon cheese and then
they just come in there screaming you're
like what the [ __ ] and it's everyday
like a dude comes on you know New York
except break my heart is when it's the
kids and they're coming on like playing
music or whatever and it's like a like
three kids that are brothers or
something coming on and just kind of
panhandling and do anything and you're
on like they're on your car and you're
on a spot where it's a while between
stations orders are not going to switch
and you're just like yeah after I got
off the Statue of Liberty there was this
lady that was selling paintings that had
nothing to do with New York nothing to
do a statue of liberty was all Marvel
characters well
yeah I was just like this is the perfect
place to make some money cuz just people
coming off the Statue of Liberty the
ferry like all day long and they were
just sitting there in the perfect Parker
yeah just all right oh is this legal
he's not cross makin ya the best record
store i saw in new york was on the
corner of Houston and Christina hey I
talked about I tweeted a photo electric
I had about 50 records they were all
meant and they were all unbelievable
records you know and a guy on fourth and
Houston just had his apartment Rob did
he was [ __ ] pissed yeah I i did a
dream thing that i've never i've always
wanted to do and i'm always in new york
in the winter and this time i was like i
don't give a [ __ ] what's going on i'm
doing it i rode the f train out to coney
island and rode the cyclone nice that's
great that's awesome man and everybody
it's amazing when you live in LA in your
comedian how we go all over the place
like for a spot like we'll go to irvine
to do 15 minutes yeah we'll go to brea
will go to san diego will go to
bakersfield so everybody that totally
good yeah i'm going out to coney island
a cruel man that's how going out there
on it's like witty yeah yeah it says
it's 50 minutes you know i get on the
train of the f train sub and it just
goes straight there i was actually there
in 40 minutes it opens up you walk
downstairs and there's the roller
coaster yeah I walked over bought two
tickets I rode the front car I rode the
back car and then got cross the street
again on the subway back home did you
have to kill any warriors yeah when I
their wires but let me tell you that
thing was built in 1927 have you ever
wrote it I have not i've rode like the
knock-offs like the san diego or and
stuff like that yeah the entire car now
is covered in padding and vinyl hahahaha
I mean it looks like a mental ward yeah
like complete because when you hit the
first turn now you need somebody in the
car because I was a solo it's slam me
the geez I was like full
for cuz trying to film and then the next
turn slam me over here back and forth it
is a [ __ ] as you did you hear that yeah
I was trying to film next vlog degree I
had my arm up he merely went down from
the geez I slammed into the turn but
what a [ __ ] ride man it is uh good
for you it is so [ __ ] you go up the fur
the first hill and you look and there's
the classic the kind of the dropper I'd
that you see in the Warriors and then
the wheel the Rope the ferris wheel
wheel a world or something and then
there's the ocean and [ __ ] the
boardwalk and it's just classic American
man just America you know like wow and
everybody's having a great [ __ ] time
yeah i'm such a West Coast snob where I
feel like an East Coast beach like who
the [ __ ] wants to watch the sunrise at
the beach it just feels weird to me to
be at the beach and have the sunset
behind you yeah like I'd want to go to
like the alcove we're like you go out
and then around and then there's still
beaching you're watching the sunset like
to me a beach is a sunset and it just
seemed like weird like you go to Coney
Island it's getting dark oh yeah it's
setting behind and you just kind of
leave I don't know uh you know it's it
to me it's more of like the history of
the place you think about the Warriors
you think about Annie Hall and and and
which by the way I saw the new Woody
Allen film mm-hmm but you think about
Woody Allen and you think about the
[ __ ] the families back in the I'm in
1927 that thing must have been beyond
fast now we're in cars and should they
go 150 miles an effort but this thing
goes like 60 can you imagine in 1927
being like one of the first riders that
thing and just going what the [ __ ] well
that's what so I helped host the Alamo
Drafthouse did a screening of star wars
episodes 4 5 and 6 here at the Ace Hotel
the ACE theater I love it and
got to help host that and it was my
first time in the ACE and this is also
like a 1920s theater or a beautiful
[ __ ] gorgeous Steve and I went it's
incredible and this place was EJ I am
it's like 1600 people or whatever it
yeah to the gills sitting there on stage
and just thinking about like how
mind-blowing this place is and how
mind-blowing it must have been in the
20s but then I'm thinking maybe it
wasn't because if you were a fluent
enough to go to the theater that's how
all theaters were that's how you
expected it so I feel like maybe maybe
conia like you knew you were getting
into her now it's like you go to Six
Flags like that sucks only what idiot
mall or like back then I'm sure it was
impressive but you geared up for it
you're like we're doing this thing we've
got the thing or anything because most
people were you know sitting in their
slump still not working 20-hour days
sending their kids to work being covered
in soot and whatever else the [ __ ] they
were doing and you try to make it right
dressed up back in the day to go to the
theater he went out and did something
yeah are we raising I i wish i'm gonna
google it or youtube it and see if
there's any footage of the first right
yeah i would love to see those people
because i mean it would be so scary
because you've never been on anything
like that before and you get on and back
then you know it's like a lot better
didn't know that that's what they got
now back t he just held onto the thing
oh [ __ ] they still have the original cat
a bar you beg gotta call it scrub it hey
what's going on you're on the air hey
i'm calling in for Steve eight Henry
yeah he's here man how you doing this is
steve what's up bud who's this Steve
Steve Sean Jackson calling from what
sort of Florida what's up man why why
all night not too much what's going on
glad to see you um you know this guy
Sean I was when I first people I met
when I moved to Los Angeles he's an act
he was an actor out here and
using me magician we used to go out to
the clubs and go everywhere he used to
just like impress people with his palm
reading and he was just he was my
wingman basically yeah and then he got
married and moved to Florida with the
New York then went back to Florida how
you doing Shawn we're talking about
summer vacations man Wow personal calls
on the show hey man I was calling about
your trip it's your mom I put on my face
hilarious well I actually actually
wanted to um you know get good Steve to
uh to admit something from a comedy
standpoint you know on the air well but
let's see if he recalls this so Steve
with do you remember do you remember
doing the crab walk or the bridge at a
popular club oh no in Los Angeles the
crab all right so i can answer this
question actually that's a part of one
of my sets now the crab blog is
something i used to do where i would get
on the ground on my back and then kind
of push myself up using my hands behind
my head oh yeah the popular dance move
you see across the nation and i would
that was what i would use to impress
women I'd be like watch this because no
one else in here you're single there
must have been [ __ ] city yeah jump it
on your dick is raised up in the air and
falling all over that's part of I said
is that I used to think that that would
get me all kinds oh my god nice to look
at me like this dude is crazy yeah Sean
I do remember I like the way Sean was
probably sitting there like as the anti
wingman being like this [ __ ] fool yo
baby I don't know how let's get out of
here and now he's very unhappy in
Florida wins yeah hey bunny with steve
was just in for it and didn't visit you
so not too good of friends I guess hey
he should have moved to Pensacola yes I
should move closer oh well hey Steve let
me just say congrats man you know you
know love you to death and thank you out
of everything you know just so I'm just
since you you you already put it out
there in terms of your prowess you
should go ahead and tell everyone about
the time we went out and you told um I
guess a group of girls that there's
search for 22 short and you actually
dare one event or two I'll make out with
you and and and and they did oh my gosh
you remember that story taking off yeah
that's super wingman John did you just
open up the spank bank like what
memories are we going through buddy one
time ice cream lady thanks for calling
shun I love you man okay thanks a lot
take care of it all right what do you
been doing while we were gone spice uh
lots of stuff a lot of riding yeah right
in what comedy or TV stuff TV stuff TV
stuff trying to gear up for marches
traditional writing staffing season here
so March March that's a long ways away I
got to get my so people that don't know
like my writing partner I wrote on
devious maids last year and we still
keep in touch but he kind of left the
business yeah so I'm trying to get for
the past two years everything we had I
had written for TV is co-written so I'm
just trying to build up my solo stuff
all right now I have two pilots and one
speck kind of out and just kind of
getting back out into the world as a
solo person and then I've been diving in
some more video games i bought a VR
headset you need to go great you're the
one that goes on your phone or no I
bought an oculus rift which is like the
the big one for my monster computer that
I have at home in my office great and
it's incredible and i bought a fancy
chair i got my first fancy desk chair
ever herman miller aeron chair and I'm
like oh I feel like I'm back in a law
firm again I actually did you actually
go to a store to get that or did you too
Dean Del Rey carry it down a hill yeah
you know wrote it down the hill what are
you doing carrying oh and wanted to but
it was beautiful so I got an aeron chair
and here's the [ __ ] hilarious that is
nuts so I'm out exercising every day now
and I which by the way you look good dad
thanks man yeah I lost 30 pounds
incredible crazy right yeah 30 all it
takes is one motorcycle accident a sore
neck and finding out that acai berries
are bad for you yeah so um I live on
this kind of
normal street but two streets behind me
it's mansion City yeah yeah yeah which
is and it's beautiful you know which by
the way I was as us hating my area but
love my apartment has hated my area cuz
I was like man I don't know anybody
around here and stuff man this is [ __ ]
i got to get back to Hollywood but as I
couldn't let home this time who is the
first time it kind of felt like home get
that great barber shop right there man
don't leave I gotta come by to visit you
so I can get my ten dollar haircuts you
want a gray tomorrow I'm gonna get
haircuts why can't I go thursday ok
thursday let's go thursday yeah i'll
call them and make appointment ok ok so
anyway I ride through this neighborhood
every day and i love it i like i like i
love architecture i love looking at
homes it just it i love it now you
always tell bur about it like a dude
I've been in their house yeah I go to
open house and I love all that [ __ ] so I
was riding through this neighborhood and
I ride through it every day it's because
it's on this heart hill and as I go I
see their staging a house to sell yeah
yeah yeah and they're putting a new
furniture and they've thrown the other
right like if you don't know they'll
take furniture people that you would
used to live in a house and they put in
stuff that photographs well and it looks
great but then when you go in there
you're like wait the couch isn't facing
the TV yeah that's not the point the
point is a looks pretty Rep yeah so I
roll up on no I wasn't on my bike I was
jogging this day cuz I bike now I didn't
have the bike yet and I look and there's
an aeron chair right at the garbage and
I go what's what's going on either the
wheels of God to be broken I because why
would you throw that away and I get
closer and closer and it's meat I mean
[ __ ] perfect yeah and then what seven
hundred dollars or something more new
yeah yeah I'm from like an office
liquidation where it's like some calm
and the Bay Area went under kind of back
recently so some guy probably lost his
job and killed himself I got a dope
chair for anyway I got two for free back
when I lived in san fran one of the
dot-coms closed and the guy goes hey my
office crows come down grab chairs they
were great Adam at the HUD for playing
guitar so instead of Dean calling an
uber XL yeah did you do Dean well I
grabbed it
yeah i can i can just [ __ ] it I'll just
carry this home they're heavier the base
is heavier than you there it's a
well-made chair I'm carrying it up again
that's not 103 out I only get about I
don't know uh maybe 200 300 feet and I
go oh this is [ __ ] now I'm like really
I really want his chair another time my
back spin father my necklace [ __ ] you
know yeah and I was like I can podcast
in this chair the chair and I can listen
to records in this chair I gotta have
this chair yeah so I lift it over my
head just start walking in a rich
neighborhood you joined CrossFit you
don't even know it we're looking at me
like roots people like did this guy just
robbed so I cuz I'm tatted out god so
good that's your wife yeah yeah you'd be
dead you'd be dead if you want away so
yeah right just breathe so I'm killing
it and then I would set it down and then
I would sit for a while to rest I crook
ah well supremo job might just be
sickness yeah I in them in there in the
Hills it's [ __ ] great I get it home
it takes me an hour yeah I've set it
down I drink like two gallons of water
and then I show Steve where I got that
tiki we're gonna know you just told me
Oh phone I still haven't actually seen
it yet oh you haven't seen it oh shiz
like that's quitting tarantino's house
there's a i went back and figured it out
on the GPS two miles nice to my was the
30 pounds right there that was the
entire [ __ ] work out you should see
it it's me every day and it's the
upgrade when it's the leather one ok
yeah so you got the ones with the net
and everything it's got the neck but the
arms or whether yeah and the back piece
here is leather and it's [ __ ] primo
yeah now we're podcast guests come over
they all grabbed it they sit hey that's
my chair you're a good guess yeah yeah
that's good that's one of the funny
things about being a hardcore single
person to is you'll commit to taking
that chair down there yeah will not
commit to a relationship
was only in my life there's only two
miles in an hour you know what I mean if
it wasn't [ __ ] in life I can't wait to
see it yeah yeah yeah you got to come
over so anyway I wanted if anybody's
listening from New York I want to say
thank you I had the best time of my life
my summer vacation was in New York I had
dreamed of being in New York in the
summertime I hadn't been there since
2006 in the summer every time I'm there
it's in the winter yeah and New York in
the summer is incredible it's its
hottest [ __ ] it stinks like I said the
stench is is New York's bully it's just
[ __ ] bullying any anywhere you go
it's just what is the [ __ ] smells I
really can't believe it and as happy as
that sounds cuz everybody says what's
the son I never had realized how bad it
was until you walk from the stand home i
was walking every night home I was just
like what the [ __ ] is going on and and
they got a new thing in New York I want
to tell everybody about that is I call
it home was TV ok so New York's mayor
has talked in the sem private company
has dropped these things all over New
York and it's a test for America they
look like a like a kind of a big big pay
phone booth like a big phone birth and
it says free Wi-Fi oh yes about these
yeah ok and and what it is is it's just
and there's no way a friends of mine a
couple friends of mine are really really
paranoid but it's a it's a it's a
[ __ ] info stealer so this company has
agreed to put them all over New York and
you plug in you got free Wi-Fi you can
watch [ __ ] they got a screen you can
watch TV on the other thing but when you
plug it in ok it doesn't give you the
outlet you have to do the the court you
know they what do they call it use their
a USB cord or whatever
speed cord and it takes all your info
huh come on yeah man I'm legal now right
does it sound like this sounds like Dean
went to New York and got it now you're
telling about Mount Shasta but no no no
what did it what it what it is is they
say that they're collecting info for
advertisers and stuff in exchange for
free Wi-Fi and stuff hmm so no citizens
are using them it's homeless it's like
now that i took a picture a guy had a
mattress uh-huh yeah two of a box spring
and mattress nice and a dog and his lady
and they were just laying in bed in
front of it on Third Street and 16
uh-huh and just watching TV and surfing
the net ya like like bizarre we got
Wi-Fi in our apartment now you saw the
photo I took of the guy I did it's just
I was I was just thinking myself that's
New York and that's what makes it
beautiful it has character yeah yeah I
love it but I class New York man yeah
huh where was the last time you gone oh
maybe two years ago last year I go out I
was going off fairly often because
improv versus stand up the show I used
to do out here at UCB it still runs at
UCB New York hello I go out the Del
Close marathon is a big improv comedy
marathon hosted at UCB New York so I
went out there are four that I probably
two years ago was last time I didn't go
this past year it was only a year ago
they just had one but it's always in the
summer and it's awesome it's great and
then a couple times I went out for like
big video game events and stuff like Oh
what is hitting us to hang out with
Robert Kelly Bobby Kelly let me do his
podcast big Jay oakerson it did his
podcast I did 21 spots at the stand yeah
all the comics were [ __ ] amazing
let's grab this call real quick what's
going on you're on the air hello yep Oh
yep yo Dean yeah you're way behind go
ahead and turn the radio now grab better
purple hello yep all right I can hear
you guys better serve up that I was
watching your life I wish few guys in a
while I was
were [ __ ] three that's what we're
talking about summer vacations it was
epic Steve henry dr doll 48 states I
went on tour and spicier oh I lit a
bunch of fires around kellett Southern
California if you guys weren't here I
just lighting fires everywhere Wow just
did a fire Donna he just did it for the
Instagram sky pigs yeah what uh what he
what he got going dude who is this and
where you come from cool lost him I
gotta run ah so see you hopefully
thursday if not before XD i'm so glad
you recognized by huh and then we're
back baby yeah yeah we're bad so great
back all right I'm not dying California
I was actually a trick you guys out well
you're in a serious delay be calling
from the past yeah yeah yeah but see you
spice okay ah alright thanks for coming
in man there's some kind of a problem we
gotta get rid of that cuz it's just uh
it makes for some bad ray oh thanks
anyway um yeah I want to get some guy
some shout out so here real quick oh
yeah go for that I met while I was there
some comedians uh let me see her because
they were just so man there was such
cool people even the mics I did in New
York you did the comedies different you
just know it immediately like those guys
man they right yeah lot all right
ehrenberg awesome awesome what if this
guy's a monster host he would host a lot
of the shows at the stand and just
[ __ ] kill it look him up on on
Instagram and then Mike for Noah we
became great friends he's a grateful
dead freak and I know he's sad today
because we lost Jerry Garcia on this day
which is and he has a great podcast
called jam cast which I did it will be
coming out in a couple weeks and he it
was interesting to be there while I was
there this guy Mike phone oya auditioned
to be regular at the seller and so it
was cruel because
you know everybody always asks me how do
you get past at the store and all that
and it was awesome to watch the process
and the nerves going through them and
everything as he was getting ready to
audition oh you went with him to the
audition yeah yeah well you just what
what it is is you do five minutes kind
of like how the store doesn't now in the
middle of a regular show so it was a
Saturday night no sorry for the Friday
night it was wall-to-wall people sold
out which the seller is sold out every
show every night like the store they do
three a night it's like 730 ten and
midnight or something and they're all
sold out every night now they've got
another room around the corner now
because since it's sold out now they
have the village underground ran by the
seller wait so the seller is that the
one that we had yes oh no yep exactly
okay and it's a massive prestigious
comedy club yeah it's like there's
nobody no one who's going to be in well
it's like a tell its Norton it's uh uh
Bobby Kelly you know it's all [ __ ]
what's his name i love rock drawing a
blank on his name right now the dude
that was on tourgasm super tall um ken
why are we going there we go I know the
guy and I'm drawing a [ __ ] blank on
his name because I don't get to see him
anymore because he moved back to New
York Gary Goldman who's an absolute
murder one of the best comics I've seen
because he's clean and just kills man
who else was there a lot just all the
East Coast killers you know anyway so
Mike auditioned and got past that's
great yeah grats on that yeah congrats
to that and let's see who else did I
meet out there oh yeah uh [ __ ] I don't
know how to say her last name do you she
was on the roast battle Christie Aiello
I guess so hello or chai hello right she
was on the roast battle and really nice
woman I did Bobby Kelly's podcast with
her and then of course Mike Lawrence
who's coming up on an episode of this
show Michael Lawrence won the roast
battle I interviewed him on the street
in front of the stand which is a great
interview coming up let's see who else
was out there it was oh I did any trunks
uh XM radio I did trunk nation which was
it was just a great fun I it sounds like
you're really busy oh god I was crazy
busy did any of big big names drop in
while you were there well I mean you'll
get bigger than norton in a towel you
know what i mean but there go on every
night like like our guys go on at the
store every night like her and Marin and
all those those are their guys and
they're just you know just kill ya tell
is ridiculous to me unbelievable that
guy man unbelievable which by the way I
got to get the Stanhope book and read it
have you run an errand the Doug Stanhope
book man I gotta get that read that you
know yeah that's uh it's gonna be hard
to beat that summer vacation man it's
not really even a vacation you were
working it sounds like you're on
vacation though yeah but it really it
really was like as radical as New York
is it was really peaceful because it was
like I felt like you know I don't really
know anybody there and then I got new
friends right away and I felt like I was
just immediately in another world and
just I didn't MIT I didn't miss my
motorcycles I thought I would until I
got home and open the garage I was like
oh haha you know but my motorcycle uh
you know i don't i don't think if i
lived in new york i don't think i would
have it you know yeah well goodness I
wouldn't I don't ride motorcycles but I
don't think if I did I wouldn't ride one
in New York I saw guys right and every
day yeah the streets are just [ __ ]
yeah I don't know how they do it and
then it had that movie with those guys
we ride the bicycles without brakes
unbelievable I go through the city and
deliver stuff oh that's just nuts I
guess you have to grow up there and be
in that culture to do that kind of stuff
yeah but I know what you're talking
about with peace because I mean I you
know people when i first started my trip
driving through New max
co in Arizona you know i would kind of
like tweet and say hey whoo this is kind
of scary it's late at night I'm going
through New Mexico there's nothing out
here and then after a while it was just
this calm I was just like you know what
I'm out here if something happens I have
a degree I'm smart I'm an adult I'll
figure it out and then I was just calm
yeah but then everything was great and
then of course everything just fell in a
place like seeing you seeing old friends
was crazy i am lee they just all fell in
the place no car trouble or anything
that's the thing i was about to say my
toyota prius yeah brand never had one
issue brand-new brand-new my butt in
november now it has 29,000 miles on it
crazy and when i got to charlotte north
carolina shout out to the toyota guys
over there i did a maintenance check
over there and i went there it was a
Saturday I went there 745 a.m. when they
were open at eight the guy was like we
can get you in and out I'm like I don't
have an appointment Manny wash my car
took care of my car and boom went back
to the hotel Wow no issues Wow I was the
only time the major time I was really
worried about whether or not something's
gonna happen with my car was between
Sturgis and Bowman yeah when I was going
from South Dakota to North Dakota and I
couldn't see anything for miles on
either side of me isn't Mount Rushmore
amazing my Rushmore is is crazy don't
get it and you're just like how how did
that happen it's unbelievable you just
have to stare at it for a while actually
i SAT there and just stared at it yeah
me too you know um I don't know what's
wrote you went in but as I rode up my
Harley I've been a stir just six times
and I ride them I go to [ __ ] Mount
Rushmore every time it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter and as soon as you turn
this one corner you see one of the
presidents noses through the trees yeah
uh and i think it's uh lincoln and you
go whoa whoa man just a nose yeah and
you're and your adrenaline kind of goes
like you go oh man that [ __ ] looks
cool with [ __ ] cuz you seeing photos all
your life you know and then I turned a
corner went up a few things parked and
walked up to the thing and I was like
that is [ __ ] incredible yeah all that
gravel down but
lo there's gravel down below it is like
a little forest down below and the you
know they got the rock formations all
the way at the top and you just think to
yourself and it looks the incline looks
really dangerous he's just like man how
did that guy do that and they said he I
mean what what yeah he had 400 workers
with him the way he did it to where he
was on the ground and he looked at the
model mm-hmm and then he would radio up
to him or whatever he would send message
or whatever and be like okay to the left
a little I don't even know how you
[ __ ] even do that I wonder it took it
took what 13 years to build that yeah
whoa it would have been quicker but
there was like a war or we're going on
or whatever and they had to stop for a
while or there was a war and they never
finished one of the presidents it was
something I can't remember but um here's
the thing too about Mount Rushmore is
it's funny because you get there once
again I don't ride motorcycles but you
get there you look at it it's amazing
and then you just kind of look around
and you go huh okay that's it so if you
travel to South Dakota just to go see
that you're just like okay so what else
is there South Dakota especially rapid
city in Hill City with where Mount
Rushmore is it has everything yeah the
rock formation you got crazy horse you
got badlands i King the badlands there's
a dinosaur museum fishing Dixon go away
I was like what the hell I could come
here for two weeks and just chill yeah
and there's always something to do
golfing it's beautiful until I leave it
like Mount Rushmore is pretty much
surrounded just by like heaven and when
you don't go down Sturgis everything's
50 Cent's gas is like a dollar hotels
are like thirteen dollars twenty-five
out like it's cuz it's like this old
little [ __ ] town of Sturgis you know
Rapid City's all updated and everything
but Sturridge is ancient you know yeah I
met this guy in in Montana and he was
telling me that I was I guess I was
there during the middle of all the stuff
that's going up right going on at
Sturgis and I drove through and it was
just as just saw all these like huts and
people buying stuff and all these
motorcycles and RVs and I'm like what
the hell is going on here I was actually
gonna text you and be like Dean what the
hell's going on his third yeah so I met
this guy in Montana and he'll
yeah that's this is the year for that's
two weeks there's not be there and it's
going to be hard to get a hotel I was
going to try and go over there but and
it the hotel prices hit I was in
Billings Montana yeah and it spread all
the way out the billing let me tell you
how it works it's [ __ ] robber I've
been going to Sturgis for years when I
first went I stay every year at a place
called Cadillac Jack's in Deadwood
Deadwood's exactly the same as it was
from back in that TV show Deadwood
although that was a set Deadwood never
changed its the same it's [ __ ]
amazing if you if you if you ever travel
and go to Deadwood how far is that from
Sturgis it's like 15 minutes it's all in
the same kind of area you got like dead
wood you got [ __ ] Mount Rushmore it's
like a big loop yeah so I stay at a
place called cadillac jacks and the
first year I went it was 225 and night
and two beds so it's a good that's
pretty good it's like a hundred bucks a
guy two guys split a room next year it
was like 250 all good I was gonna go
last year which was the 70th they had
fluctuation prices the first part of the
week of Sturgis is way hotter than the
second week popular wise yeah so the
first part of the week it was a thousand
and night whoa that was it a night and
you had to buy three nights oh my god
minimum yeah and now the only reason I
stay there is it's the only place with
parking underground everywhere else use
park on the street but they have massive
hail they're like every other day it'll
just be [ __ ] hailing and it's like
rocks pounding your motorcycle you can
hear it it's like thinking can clinking
you King King King King King King King
Kong KKK guys paints just getting [ __ ]
I never noticed any halo I was driving
but man the rain drops out there are you
mom yeah I can hear them like what the
hell is going on out there yeah yeah his
energy dollars a night that is yeah well
they know the popularity yeah the price
of that hotel not during Sturgis 39
haha $39 that's like Coachella like yeah
we're close to Coachella yeah they pay
you to go there any other time of the
year yeah we coach are like please come
out to the desert won't give you dinner
yeah yeah like no one wants to go out
there you know yeah I was driving
through sturgeon and thinking yeah this
is the Coachella for bikers yeah yeah
and I guess they have I saw billboards
they have rockers and concerts and stuff
they're all huge bands huge bands like
arrows I saw Aerosmith Daris I allysin
chaynes is kiss played their guns and
roses played there they don't [ __ ]
around this is the biggest bike rally of
all the world and people come from
around the world and I think this year's
number 71 so think fit when when it
comes to a hundred you know I won't even
be alive what is the 30 more years in
Haiti but when it turns a hundred i wish
i was alive just to go see it's gonna be
a scary bikers haha cuz the 50 year they
had like two million bikers or something
or a million but it's like out of
control the town hold is like 60 people
this guy was so funny in it then I met
in Montana I went to a bar chop house
and I sat at the bar eight and had a
drink and this guy was there he's from
Montana I was talking to him he made me
think about you because because he was
like yeah these jerseys idiots out there
who they got these vans or they got
these RVs and they drive up yeah they
park somewhere and then they ride in
like Oreo bikers and I was like yeah
come on you gotta do the whole bike okay
the desert they got the shirt that says
I rode mine and other shirts to say like
[ __ ] your trailer usually with a queen
or whatever you know with every dress
I'm riding as a ride there you ride
right by trailers you know you're like
what are you doing you got now some
bikes aren't made to ride far but if
you've got a bagger and you're putting
it on a trailer and driving it to
Sturgis you're just a dick because that
bike is made to eat up miles it's made
to go far it's comfortable it's a so my
road king is a sofa yeah you put the
shield
his ride cruise control that's what it's
for but these guys are [ __ ] yeah they
pull around the corner take them off
than they roll in throw some bugs on his
[ __ ] long oh man leather coat it was
crazy yeah I saw a couple bikes where uh
what are those the three wheelers yeah
trike and I remember you were you kept
talking about him when we did a drive
somewhere and you're like oh those
aren't real riders yeah so funny i would
go trike as if I zolder though yeah you
know actually I I clown the trike
because you can't split lanes that's the
only reason I don't like the truck okay
cuz it's you have to drive it like a car
yeah yeah you might as well get a
convertible car yeah of course you want
to still ride I get it you know if
you're an old dude [ __ ] yet they're
badass but I realized as i get older i
would love to take a trike to Sturgis
because it has a big trunk so you can
open the trunk and pack it with your
stuff oh no then since you're on three
wheels you don't need to be looking at
the road you know what I mean you can
actually drive it like a car and now
enjoy the scenery that you're riding
around he's [ __ ] on a three wheel
you're not like whoa you know what I
mean and so I think the trike is the
ultimate ride out to Sturgis as an older
dude just cruising with your [ __ ] in the
trunk cold drinks and [ __ ] nice yeah
hell yeah I did notice though like
because I also went to Scotland in
Canada you know after a wild man related
to Scotland falooda Scotland but driving
through Canada you after a while you
just look around you're just like wow
everything is the same trees the view
the vistas the only difference is how
you take everything in yeah like you
just sitting there like oh wow okay what
kind of tree is that look at these the
cloud formations were gorgeous across
the country man they kept changing and
depending on there's a fire or of it
rained yep yeah but I know how to
appreciate all that kind of stuff so
well I'm glad you're back dude oh man
I'm I'm glad I'm back but you know now
with you know I got a ticket my new
we're ticket for dropping someone off a
dime back home just like my pitch in the
face right back to North Dakota life
it's in the face when you come home from
vacation face that's always the weirdest
thing about vacation and we'll wrap it
up on this it's like you come home and
you've decompressed from this vacation
yeah and and you're just like oh yeah
and as soon as you open the mailbox real
life comes [ __ ] back out and hit you
in the face and also I remember I was
driving down from California I'm like
all right I'm at my last state i'm going
home I can't wait to decompress it's
almost like someone was tracking me I
get a phone call from someone who's like
hey man so let's get this website going
I'm like man I haven't even gone home
yet and touched my bed yeah well already
need help me up yeah yeah so I just
gotta gotta get back to the grind while
we're alive all right everybody thanks
for tuning in Steve follow him on
Instagram and Twitter I Steve Henry
thanks for having me but absolutely and
of every man what a great great trip you
did and also a spy sir follow him spicer
on twitter and christian underscore
spicer on Instagram and i'm dean del rey
and thanks again don't forget to rate
and review and subscribe to this podcast
the more people that subscribe I can't
say it over and over it makes it higher
in the ratings and I was number 182
today which is great any time you're in
the top 200 it's [ __ ] happening
that's awesome thank you and all one
last thing i'll be at the comedy store
all weekend this comes out on thursday
so today's would be a thursday i will be
in the main room on friday or sorry
Saturday night main room ten o'clock
show and uh oh someday I'm gonna be in
salt lake city utah headlining one night
at wiseguys this sunday the 14th come
out [ __ ] yeah I can't wait man i did
Salt Lake a couple weeks ago with alice
in chains what a great town can't wait
to go back so come out to wise guys
thanks for tuning in guys see ya candles
lit